now to Louisiana the state now with more
than 18,000 positive coronavirus cases
in over 700 deaths
Louisiana lawmaker one of the Louisiana
lawmakers is one of the ones who lost
his battle with the corona virus
yesterday he was 54 years old Casey
steagle is now live on all of that from
Arlington Texas he has more kaci sander
good morning the lawmakers son that you
speak of confirming the information that
so many people had feared that he lost
his dad after a battle with coronavirus
yesterday he was hospitalized last week
and then he was put on a ventilator
he just took office in January of this
year to represent Louisiana House
District 54 though Reggie Begala
was not new to public office he
previously served as an administrator
and then auditor of his local parish the
news coming on a day that health
officials in New Orleans reported a
decline in the number of deaths over a
24-hour period across the state more
than 18,000 people however have tested
positive 700 to have died government
leaders have been calling for more Cova
19 tests to be brought to the region the
federal government is still running some
of its drive-thru testing sites but most
testing now being done at hospitals
doctors offices and Clinics although you
can add major national pharmacy chains
to the list the federal government is
now allowing registered pharmacist
across the country to administer
coronavirus tests once they're trained a
handful of Walgreens locations already
offering drive-through testing sites CVS
Walmart and others are expected to come
online soon however with a big holiday
weekend upon us leaders say now is not
the time to start ignoring social
distancing guidelines there is light at
the end of all this darkness and I did
want to encourage the people of
Louisiana to look at it in that fashion
I encourage them to continue to comply
with all the orders that are in place
and to be patient
the same message is also being
circulated across Texas and other states
across the country here in Texas 199
deaths have been reported numbers still
relatively low considering the size and
population of the Lone Star State Sandra
Casey steagle thank you